hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
as you some of you have seen my previous
video on this
ps audio power plant p12 or 12.
um i did a bunch of tests on it and i
thought i was done with that basically i
showed that
while it does regenerate ac and cleaner
ac then my mains although does generate
some extra noise in low frequencies
showed every which way that it made no
impact on the output of either power
supplies
or the output of a real audio device
i thought i was finished with that
but then people inside the forum
started to push for uh
more testing
specifically they wanted to know how it
perform under power
psrd advertises this very low output
impedance just briefly output impedance
is the internal resistance that the
device itself has and as you pull
current that resistance because actually
can dissipate power and
and with it actually lose regulation and
some losses so psido advertises pretty
low uh output impedance near zero
basically 0.008 ohm
and people have taken that and say well
that increases the dynamic power because
surely that's better than uac mains
and the company implies that in their
marketing material just the same
so even though i had packed the unit
completely and it was ready to be
shipped back to his owner
i thought oh shoot i better do this or
he will hang around for a long time so
i went ahead and unpacked this 50 pound
monster it looks small but it's so heavy
i like the back upstairs where my lab is
and aimed to retest it
the new test was to
use a uh
this amp linear amplifier class
a b although this one is what is called
class g
um
and uh called outlaw 2220 it's a
monoblock single channel amplifier
and uh these amplifiers tend to show
more peak power than uh average power um
because they use unregulated output
rails uh output supplies and uh i
thought for sure um well sorry i'm
getting ahead of myself um let me uh
show you first what happened was that
with uh using just the raw ac power at
that moment where i'm gonna test p12
because as i said there are voltage
sensitive so
i run this test and there's two tests in
here as part of every amplifier test i
run and one is a continuous sine wave
that is fed to the unit and
the analyzer
i give it a range of input voltages and
it will step between these things either
producing too little power
for the distortion one percent that i'm
aiming at or too much distortion and it
will try to keep adjusting the output
power of the amplifier until it hits
this one percent uh thd distortion
and whatever that number winds up being
then it spits out the uh the power so
it's an iterative test it's basically
pushing the amplifier to um
at different power levels
and then the second test is a true burst
one and so this is a continuous power
but at one percent distortion and this
one is a burst rate where is 20 cycles
of one kilohertz that as that is the
same as the one on the left but for 480
cycles or
vast majority of the time it's at much
lower level the idea is that it's sort
of uh simulating what music would be
where it's at low level now suddenly you
get a peak and you know and then it does
the same thing that it does for this one
on the left to compute the power it's
actually a cea standard um called 2006
490a it was made for car amplifier guys
car amplifier guys as you probably know
if you've been in that domain they want
to advertise big numbers always and they
usually cheat and put out ridiculous
numbers this was a way to get them to
all cheat the same way and at any rate i
use it to show the dynamic power beyond
sort of continuous power indeed we see
that this amplifier puts out tons more
power when you're just excited for short
period that's because it's got internal
capacitors in the power supply that are
able to supply that power but if you
keep the amplifier going then they get
depleted and and power the voltage
droops and the power with it goes down
so we have i don't know uh 78 more power
uh when we do this so this is an ideal
candidate for any device that claims to
improve dynamic power
as this uh ps audio power plant uh p12
claims that
uh on this thing so i then
took the uh
routed the ac instead of being directly
from the wall which is what these
results are uh and routed it through uh
p12 i actually used an aftermarket uh
outlet i'll show you i mean sorry cable
power cable it's a two hundred dollar
power cable from a company called
pangaea
it looks very high end and does all the
trimmings of high-end power cables but
the price is not outrageous so
if you're really insisting on getting
fancy power cords i recommend getting
the pangaea stuff and it comes in
different lengths and different prices
on this thing but i've had it since
2017. i never get a chance to test it i
don't use it for anything except for
these special occasions
anyway
back to our comparison and let me reduce
this inside so we can see both of these
together
so when i run this exact same test but
this one routed through um the
psrd p12 power region regenerator
we see that we drop in power from 371
watts we dropped down to 340 watts about
almost eight percent power loss if this
isn't a continuous and then in the burst
power which you would think is where the
company is advertising it'll improve
things it also dropped eight percent
almost we we lost about 50 watts or 45
watts between these two instances
so this is a real live test uh it's the
latest amplifier i had that was sent to
me for measurement i didn't pick it out
of anything special i didn't know what
the results were going to be i let the
measurements speak and the measurements
are saying
no this is not doing what you think is
going to do
um
and
i've done a different test then so all
right the power loss is the power lies
but let's see if it reduce noise and
distortion and this is again a standard
test that i run is a sweep where the
input of the amplifier is gradually
increased and the analyzer measures um
thd plus n which is harmonic distortion
plus noise let me enlarge this again so
that we can see it better
um
it's into a forum load and uh
in green means again we're just plugging
into my power strip that i use for
everything and it proves produced 313
watts and you can see the dot over here
where i uh finished uh uh grabbing the
power um
but and when i plug it into p12 though
notice that the same thing happened as
before now we lost power uh almost 10
percent of our power down to 283 watts
they're kind of close in here but
there's a log display in here so a
little bit of distance here translates
to a lot of power so we lost power in
here and uh and that's not good um this
is a basically a third way of measuring
power and uh you know we didn't get
there but importantly look at how the
two graphs with or without uh ps audio
p12 they land exactly on top of each
other the part of the curve that slopes
down in these amplifier power tests is
completely dominated by noise meaning
that as we get more power the noise
becomes a smaller and smaller ratio of
it so this graph improves performance
even though nothing's improved we just
can louder and louder signal relative to
a constant noise level and we see that
the noise has not changed because if the
noise had changed the the p
with p12
the graph would have you know
come down here lower somewhere here and
it did not it sits identically to the to
the raw ac power and then when the graph
changes its slope from being that
straight line to either horizontal or it
goes up it means distortion is now the
dominant factor and
we see that when the distortion's
dominant factor nothing was improved
with p12 either so in both cases
we either see no improv we see no
improvement in fidelity and we have a
power loss
so the question is why you know uh
one would think of you know intuitively
you thought you'd get more power but
conservatively you would say same power
but we're actually losing by losing
performance and clearly the company
doesn't tell you anything about losing
performance
so uh i showed you the impedance that
the company advertises point zero zero
eight so i said well let's measure that
to measure that ac especially under load
and it's it's high voltage it's not a
trivial exercise and
you know the kind of setup you need is
very complex and of course ps audio
never tells us how they measured their
impedance either uh it just says that's
the number take a word for it it's like
yeah sure you know tell me how you
measured it whether you just computed it
on paper did you just probe the inside
of the amp and then go probe it out on
the outside across outlets and
everything
but anyway i happen to have
all these little cool tools and one of
the things i have is this little uh
analyzer is designed for electrical line
compliance testing and safety testing
it's by a company called ideal that
makes a lot of these things it's
portable you walk up to a you know
industrial uh setting and you can just
instantly plug this in you get the
voltage and you can change change the
safety of the wiring the impedance and
you can see if they're compliant with
with code and what have you uh it's
pretty good it's five hundred dollars
almost so it's not a cheap little uh oh
actually four hundred dollars sorry
fish story the cost of the
instrumentation but anyway um it's a
nifty little device it's not
instrumentation grade so i don't want to
vouch for its 100 accuracy but you know
it has that um it's really neat the way
it lets you measure the impedance which
is basically resistance to ac and you
can actually see how your hot lead in
your outlet is doing and your neutral
lead and even the ground lead these
things have different loads on them and
they may have different terminations and
the impedance may vary
i just chose to use the hot lead because
that's that's the
power source uh
on this thing so i this is my ac mains
and and my ac mains goes from outlet to
a power strip and then through a piece
of wire to this guy and so
it all those wires are included in this
measurement so the actual impedance
right at the source is probably a lot
you know lower than this every time you
have an outlet this number degrades
because you have contacts that are loose
and wires all out impedances so forth so
anyway i get 0.26
i then plugged in the uh did into uh
ps audio p12 and shockingly it's ten
times worse uh more than ten times worse
eleven times worse and i'm like whoa
this must be a mistake i plug it unplug
it and go back and repeat and
yeah it is three ohm and if it's 3 ohm
then that would explain the power losses
because that's a lot of impedance to
have inside the box as you pull current
that impedance
times the current becomes a power loss
inside the
p12
so it explained that the problem was
that as i said i didn't have high
confidence
in this meter because i had never used
it for this kind of analysis and so i
put a copy of it here in bold saying
look i uh you know i can't swear to the
this analysis here being correct but
directionally the two are supporting
each other one says that hey you've got
uh power loss and when you have high
current amplifier running and by the way
your impedance is high so that explains
the losses losses are inside the p12 but
of course you know folks say well that's
impossible then you know how could it be
the company is advertising this
ridiculously low uh uh you know
impedance so surely your measurements
are wrong
and that was the response of the company
initially just like uh amir's too young
still learning what he's doing and uh
you know he'll he'll figure it out but
you know he probably doesn't know what
he's doing
we know what we're doing and
his stuff must be wrong well that
resulted in uh
uh 23 pages
of 125 pages over here of uh
arguments and people internally on the
forum arguing with me people think it's
a walk in the park just post these
results and everybody in the forum
agrees with me they do not they
severely scrutinize what i have and many
people declare the tests wrong
and with many technical challenges and
so forth
uh but something good came out of it
throughout all those arguments was that
a
member went and contacted uh psadio and
said hey you say point zero zero eight
amir's measuring three ohm what gives
and the support person went to paul
mcgowan who's the ceo of the company and
said oh paul says that you probably use
the high current port and the high card
port isn't as good as the rest of the
ports
well let me first tell you what what
that is about if you go to the original
review i have in here
i don't know if you can
see it well but there are four sets of
outlets in here in
pairs for each one there's a zone a b c
and d
all the tests that almost all the tests
that i did in the original review was
done with zone a uh i was testing either
with no load on the unit um or i was
testing it with a headphone amplifier or
different power supplies they were all
low loads and i know from experience to
not use the
high current ones because sometimes
they're degraded for whatever reason and
so i had done all those tests in zone a
but when i went to test an amplifier
naturally i'm going to use the what the
equipment's labeled as high current it
is an amplifier is high current i wasn't
about to stick it in the low current
ports and damage the unit or have them
come back and say of course you were
supposed to use the high current port
use the low current port and if you look
at the manual of the manual
you can see that it says that
bear in mind that the p20 will output
the same voltage across all the zones so
to me that means it's regenerated and
it's proper so
you know it i looked and there's nothing
in there about something being wrong
with that port or that port having
higher impedance well
paul mcgowan went and and i don't know
if i have that post of his in here
um anyway he goes out and you can go to
the forum and read it i'm gonna get to
this punch line um but he basically says
oh that
port it's just the pass through port
it's just got some filtering on it it's
not regenerated
well
that's clearly wrong because by then i
had tested zone d the high current one
and i knew a was regenerated and i'll
show you why i know it was regenerated
with this uh first test and uh in here
i've measured zone a and zone d in my
original review and as you can see that
performs the same all the distortion has
been removed so it absolutely is
regenerated
and what paul said was flat out wrong
more importantly i
have a variable output transformer and i
plugged it in and i tested zone d and i
could adjust the voltage from 90 to 130
volts
and as i adjusted it it stayed on 120
output um so
for sure paul's statement was wrong but
anyway it doesn't matter he's claiming
that port shouldn't be you know isn't
the one you're supposed to use
okay the ceo of the company says i'm
supposed to use something else
all right let's measure another port
so i measure zone a this time with the
same meter and lo and behold i'm getting
numbers between 0.14 and 0.16 not 3 ohm
so clearly the other zones have much
lower impedance not the ridiculous .008
that uh
psaudio claims uh again that's i'm sure
internal impedance not
across power cords and and what have you
in a live system but anyway this is much
more reasonable and indeed when i repeat
the test that i just showed you
we see now that the power deficiencies
disappears if you use zone a
you get identical amount of power but
you also get identical noise and
distortion so
no improvement but no loss either so if
you zone a through c presumably um they
do this and uh around a power test again
a peak and and uh maximum and there's
still a tiny amount of power loss but
that could be because my raw ac is
slightly higher voltage than than it and
allowed the amp to run a little bit
harder or produce a little bit output
this is not an issue this is understood
so
we now verify that the zone d has an
issue on it and the question is what is
that issue
paul mcgowan is basically feeding us
misinformation there he doesn't know i
don't i don't think he's doing it on
purpose by the way i think he just
didn't know he didn't design the
equipment and whoever designed it
correctly had had it documented as i
showed you the manual that that port is
regenerated but what is going on with
that port
so
the people who own older versions of
power plant
they say that in their documentation
says that the high current ports have a
limiter in them
what is a limiter it's an inrush limiter
meaning that when you first plug into
something it tries to
lower the voltage and lower the demand
on the power plant
because if don't do that you can exceed
the current capability capabilities of
p12
and either go into protection blow fuse
or damage it so from their experience
i'm sure or whatever they realize people
when you tell people you can plug in
powerful devices into a regenerator you
better you know i shouldn't say you
better they put an in brush limiter in
there um
the problem with an inrush limiter is
that it is now going to sap all the
dynamic power that you were trying to
claim that the equipment provides as i
showed you in my testing
um the in limiter they later on post the
design engineer or one of the engineers
finally chimes in and
says oh yeah we have a thermistor in
there in line with with zone d
and the thermistor has to get warm
before it it reduces its impedance and
and they assumed that that resistor
would always get warm and
and run that way well no that's not the
case the only way that resistor can get
warm is that if you
pull max power out of the p2o
continuously
music doesn't work that way you listen
to music average power might be one to
five watts and then a peak comes and
that peak maybe 100 was 200 watts so
there's not enough question current
going through the uh
um the p12 power plant to heat up that
thermistor and basically remove this in
rush
limiting and so it's a completely
opposite design to what you want to
claim that this thing improves the
dynamics of an amplifier while it
doesn't because if it's dynamic means
peak to the averages big ratio
and
your inline emitter as my testing shows
is limiting power uh the proof again is
right at the beginning i you know i
measured it and you know we're losing
power we're losing 7.5
power in a real amplifier with real
tests so you can't say well that's just
theory but in practice it works no it
doesn't work
and at any rate this should have been in
the specification saying that the zone d
can have a high impedance up to 3 ohm or
about 20 times more than
your outlet
and don't use it
now you might say okay well i'll go use
the uh
um uh zone a my problem with zone a or
the other low current one is
they put it in right in rush in rush
limiter for a reason uh
and that reason may have been the
protected power plant
and uh
i don't know if it's safe to
pound on the low current ports without
that limiter uh is that going to damage
the unit is the voltage going to sag and
cause problems for downstream devices
and surges
uh there's a feedback mechanism in the
power plant it's just like any other
amplifier what does it do to that
it's a big mess
as a minimum i expect the company to go
and clean up the documentation clean up
the specification explain all this stuff
to people because it impacts how you use
the device every consumer up to this
point i'm sure assume that those ports
are all good and they plugged in the
power amplifiers to the high current
port that's what it says is for
and the manual confirmed that they're
just as good as the rest of them but now
we realize it isn't as good as the rest
of the zones and you better uh you know
well you're forced to use the other
ports and uh it doesn't make sense
very unfortunate is just is the tone of
language uh from the company and this is
paul mcgowan on their own forum um goes
out when he first claimed that the
power strip uh the zone d high current
it's just a power strip just got a
little filtering and it's not
regenerated
he comes out and says the responsible
thing to do is for me to revise the
review and give him an apology
uh really
i'm measuring a real amplifier plugged
into your device per instructions per
manual and it's showing power loss a
measured impedance doesn't match your
spec you have not shown one measurement
one piece of data saying why what i did
was wrong i did what every user would do
plugging their amplifier into the high
current board
and the information analysis i'm getting
does not jive with what you're
explaining and
clearly you're wrong
because i showed you that the uh that
zone d is regenerated unlike what paul
was saying so the mistake was his not
mine
well good news if we can call it is that
this morning he finally
finds out that he's screwed up um let me
reduce it in size so that you could see
that uh
it's paul mcgowan ceo ps audio this is
one thing i screwed up
on and uh
you know it
that that it does regenerate the output
yeah
we figured this out
and how you figure things out like this
measurements measurements have value if
they had done this kind of measurement
and analysis like i did plugged in the
power amplifier and measured this peak
power they would have noticed that it's
producing less speed power and they
would have either revised the design or
documented or something
and
you know it it just says it casually as
if it's still my fault or something uh
that this is the case um no it's not a
good thing to just screw up after two
weeks that i've been testing this device
to come back and idea and say i just
screwed up like now if you didn't know
how the box worked
don't talk about it yes a ceo of company
can't remember all these details forgive
him for that what i can't forgive him
for that is if war is that he goes out
and says oh this emir god doesn't know
what he's doing he should retract and
post an apology
you know
that's not the way the world turns if
you want to have a good relationship
with customers and and potential
customers in the future have done
extensive testing of this box every
which way and they haven't lifted one
finger to produce one measurement to
counter everything that i've shown you
and but yet the statements are all this
condescending things i'm you're still
learning yeah one day it'll be good but
you know these guys all just always want
to say stuff doesn't work hey i love to
say it works i like the look of the
machine hey if it improves fatality
look i'm gonna get behind it i don't
care what it cost five thousand six
thousand dollars is nothing if it
improves fidelity the problem is it
doesn't improve fidelity i mean i
you know i've tested it every which way
how do you argue with this graph
you want to tell me your noise floor
went down how did the noise flow go down
because the instrument
is trivial to measure noise it's trivial
to measure distortion
it didn't change at all it's not like a
tube amp where you added euphonic
distortion or something you could argue
it didn't do anything to the output of
the amplifiers the thing we listened to
is the thing we hook up to our speakers
it is not changing one hair it's not
like a deviated a little bit a little
bit higher we could argue over the
difference
nothing
and importantly
the company has encountered any of these
measurements
you know they make bunch of amplifiers
they make bunch of these power plants
they have an industrial ac that you
could argue
in their facility could be dirty
hook it up show some analysis show that
you know how to measure these things
show that you're understanding this
level of instrumentation analysis don't
just throw around you know ridiculous
impedance numbers
and just tell a story
and unfortunately that's how this
high-end audio
world is working you give a plausible
story
and people who are not engineers believe
this stuff
i guarantee you i can line a thousand
engineers out there design engineers
proper design engineers and every one of
them will just roll their eyes if you
say you're going to regenerate ac to
improve the performance of an audio
device that operates on dc
the the dc equipment doesn't care what
the incoming ac waveform looks like
first thing it's going to do is smash it
into a dc
and generates its own noises that you
have to filter and worry about but it is
not with like we take that 60 hertz or
modulated to play music the 60 hertz we
want to get rid of right away and that's
what your audio equipment does so it's
not a surprise that it doesn't do
anything
if you watch one of paul's videos on
motivation for why he designed got into
this business was that he thought when
you use a power conditioner or filters
or power cords
the reduced noise or something he said
but the sound is not as real anymore and
it became real when he built the first
one of these things or his company did
that's not proper motivation to go build
something you measure it first so okay
is there a difference with those power
conditioners if you had measured those
like i have you would have noticed that
nothing had changed anyway with those
power conditioners or power cables so
then he should have been prompted to go
do a blind test but he didn't know if
those things were being used or not and
see if the results are reliable and uh
without that without verification of
measurements he just jumps in and goes
creates a solution for a problem that
just doesn't exist
not just because i'm saying this because
it's just the way the design works
electronics works in the other review i
showed you how the output of power
supply dc or switching doesn't care one
bit about what you do
so anyway we could have our blood
pressure go up talking about high in
audio and how broken it is and how
company of the company just chases
expensive solutions because audiophiles
latch on to these pseudo technical
stories and believe them but hopefully
at least some of you step back and say
wait a second the optics of this is not
right either there's the ceo of the
company who's been saying i should
retract my video with my uh
review then it comes like it says oh
gosh i i didn't realize i i you know
i said the wrong thing you know this
thing does have an in rush limiter right
here
has a 3 ohm inverse limiter exactly what
i measured so why did he say that
measurement was wrong
the measure was measurement was 100
correct his original response if he knew
what he was talking about was to say hey
yeah that's correct you know the 3 ohm
it does have a 3 ohm limiter you can't
use it for power amps and if he had said
that then his own customers would go
back to him say whoa i've got my power
amp plugged into that book what is it
doing and
get a you know proper thing instead it
just we get flipping things he says the
manual doesn't say anything because not
made for people who are going to measure
it
oh really
come on it is useful information for
every customer to know that the high
current port in this device reduces
dynamic power
opposite of the
what the companies say
anyway let me get back to the
rest of the testing i did um
i also went and tested an amplifier with
that's class d and uses a switching
power supply and here even when using it
on zone d it makes no difference um i'm
showing you the power difference in here
again rise he produced just a hair more
but that's not consequential
why doesn't it make a difference because
a switching power supply is a power
regenerator that's exactly what what it
does it takes ac converts it to dc
converts it to a square wave ac and then
switches a very high frequency not at 60
hertz that
power plant does and because of very
high frequency the uh
electromagnetic components get very
small that's why switching power supply
are efficient and small and because
they're doing it smartly they're
regenerating power in a smart manner and
when they regenerate the power they
could care less
if you filter the original ac or not the
first thing they do is knock it down to
dcm filter
so
um anything you have that's switching
it's just silliness to plug in this
monster in front of it when it's already
regenerating its own power so the moment
you see a you know searching power
supply adapter that's external or
internal or or if you have class t
amplifier
none of those devices by definition care
or want and again even linear ones don't
care but anyway
here i actually use the high impedance
zone d and and they didn't care still
because that impedance didn't matter it
regenerated its own power
so where are we on on this thing bottom
line is it's simple
uh in every test that i've run
either the it does nothing useful
or if you use the wrong outlet zone d
with high power devices you lose power
the net is either the same
or you lose something
not one test has been produced by the
company or any other outfit
any other reviewer
that counters what i've just shown you i
believe stereophile tested the p12 but
unlike the norm did not measure it
why
not measure it that's you know that
magazine normally measures things why
didn't they measure maybe they didn't
know how to measure it i couldn't fault
them you do need specialized
instrumentation to measure uh uh the ac
line but you know they could have hooked
up an amplifier measure this power
before and after instead of just
accepting the word of the company
so
bottom line is very simple
extensive analysis across
two to three weeks
everything people said well you know it
could do this it could do that it's just
the conclusions are solid as a rock
and the company hasn't produced one
measurement to counter any of it all
they do is say
you know who knows they don't know what
they're doing
anyway we've shown that we do know what
we're doing we figured out what the
device does before paul mcgowan did
the other thing was that just repeatedly
gets said in in these reviews well he
just measures and doesn't listen and uh
if a reviewer doesn't listen it doesn't
matter
i mean you got to be crazy if i say
here's a glass of water i pour from a
you know a filtered water in one glass
and i pour the same thing in the second
glass
are you really going to do a taste test
between those two when you know that the
same bottle was used to put water in
both glasses is identical what's the
point of doing that test you know in
advance that there can't be any
difference when i'm not
sitting here wasting my time looking for
details differences that i know does not
exist there's nothing being impacted on
the output of the audio devices as
measured
remember that the advertising for this
company
and many in likum only talks about what
it does to the ac it never ever talks
about what it does to the output of your
audio devices there's no measurements or
anything they just imply that there's
there is improvements there anyway i
could argue these points to death or i
could just do the bloody test so fine i
set up two tests one a headphone test
and the other one speaker test one of
the reviews ps audio post was with
headphone review a headphone testing
review and the other one was i think
with speakers so i did both um it was a
very resolving as they call expensive uh
chain it was a thousand dollar rme adi2
deck uh driving a topping a 90 which i
think is six seven hundred dollars
and then the output of that uh drove
this dan clark stealth headphone
it's a
it's my everyday headphone uh it's a
closed back it's it is four thousand
dollars a lot of money so proving that
we're not cheap when performance is good
i you know i bought this because i
wanted to keep it after i got the review
sample
and uh
this is superb
it has the lowest distortion i've ever
measured on on a headphone and being
closed back means it isolates outside
noise so i can hear if there's noise
difference between
devices that i'm testing and certainly
this is a higher end chain than just
about anything any reviewer has on this
thing so about a six thousand dollar
chain i'm using and that's not including
the sources and so forth uh funny thing
is the moment i started listening to the
raw ac first just plug into my power
strip and then i move the plug into the
p12 and immediately i thought that p12
sounded better
exactly what everybody's impression it
it's like a shock to my system like whoa
we got better i've explained why these
things happen before we can see as soon
as i plugged it in i said pay attention
to what the difference was and
immediately have a different impression
than when you're casually listening and
so i unplugged it plugged it back to ac
mains and i was like oh wait a second
same improvements up there too i said
listen carefully and i did that three or
four times and then by then they just
sounded the same so definitely not
conclusive um that there's any
difference whatsoever but i heard a
difference so the people who say he
measured first therefore he was inclined
to not hear a difference i'm being frank
with you i i did hear a difference it
just wasn't a real difference and it
faded away
for speaker testing um
i use my regular two-channel system it's
a pretty high-end system
i don't usually talk about it because i
don't want to brag about stuff like this
i know there are some voyeurs out there
just buy stereo coping so they can say
how expensive their stuff is but in this
case i had to brag about how expensive
it is because somehow people think i
only want to look for cheap stuff that
does well no i
pay a ton of money
to have things that are nice to look at
and of course perform well so this is my
system and
the testing that i did was with this
mark levinson 532 reference amplifier
it's discontinued but i think when it
was new is twenty thousand dollars it's
about 120 pounds stereo amplifier
uh i think it's rated at 400 watts into
eight home and uh 800 watts a channel
into a forum so amazing beast it's first
power it drives uh two reversal on twos
um the rev revels uh i think they retail
for 23 000
so uh combined that's about forty three
thousand dollars i have a two thousand
dollar matrix uh audio streamer on deck
in here and a silent pc i built for
streaming
uh and hosting my roon core on it and um
so overall we're talking about a fifty
thousand dollar system uh it's
incredibly good sounding uh every day i
wake up kiss the ground that i could
afford to put together a system like
this it just puts a smile on my face
anyway you can't argue that i try to use
a 500
you know thing or you know hooked up an
iphone with a
earphones and try to test
and uh i uh listen to this system let me
see if i find my review again
and uh ironically i started with ac feed
and to make things really bad i actually
took a little thin power strip you know
there's a gp five dollar ones
and powered the
amplifier using that so to exaggerate
really bad power
and then i unplugged the uh the
amplifier from that thin power supply
plugged it into ps audio p12 which was
being powered by that thick uh pangaea
cord
an immediate impression i had was
actually lord fidelity this time not the
same but lower fidelity i thought it
sounded more compressed and congested
um
but of course that was also
just random impression a plug back into
the thin power strip
and it sounded the same and i went back
and forth a few times it was the same
uh the test of course was all cited uh
you might say why aren't you doing blind
tests blind test of what there's nothing
here to test to know but every claim was
made that you know proper reviewer tests
by listening no proper reviewer they're
pointing to
is using blind testing so if you want to
if you want me to be a proper reviewer
do testing just like you do and just
like they do i did and i reported my
observations frankly and
i was actually sad there were
differences but they vanished
differences for good and differences for
bad so this is what you wanted you got
it now this is why i don't post them
because it doesn't have any value it is
not a proper test for somebody just
stick something in there and say well
the sound improved and waxed poetically
about how the mids did this and the veil
was removed it's just silliness you know
on this thing
so
bringing us to a close uh
i really wish that uh
psalia would go back to the
beginning
run these tests themselves they don't
have to tell us anything they could just
run it internally
you know and say hmm are we really
selling people stuff that doesn't work
or actually degrades their stuff
and with people like me who got nothing
else to do in life than sit there make
youtube videos and test our products
with expensive gear
maybe they gig the gig is up uh and we
don't want to suffer like this in the
future let's make money from stuff that
works and performs and
not stuff like this that just you know
they make technical claims if if this
thing just made some
superfluous comments it'd be one thing
but they pretended there are technical
reasons why this device works better but
those technical reasons don't pass
muster they just they violate the
engineering design principles of how
equipment works
please paul mcgill if you care about
future of your company
get on the straight path produce
products that people care
low noise low distortion high power high
fidelity transparency if you want to
build non-transparent stuff cool
make it clearly known that the stuff's
non-transparent don't claim that they're
better if unless you have some
controlled blind testing that shows
they're better
they've got this system and equipment in
place to do proper testing but of course
they're not
so
you know i
i'm trying to be as generous as i can
with my comments given the you know
really amazing hostility that that's
come back from the company only posting
in their own forum during this entire
time they haven't contacted me once they
could contact me i don't bite i love to
hear from companies plenty of companies
whose products i review that don't
perform by the way they contact me
you know some unhappy some appreciate it
some say okay in the next version we're
going to xyz thank you for doing the
testing or how did you do this test can
we have the test files for all the
precision sure here we go
what can i do to help uh if you have the
next generation products you want me to
test them like this for you happy to do
it um i'm here as a service
there's all this talk about i do all
this stuff for views and things there's
no advertising on my forum there's no
advertising on this video i am fortunate
enough to not need to make money off of
of this online venture
and
members are kind enough to donate but
you know the view counts and things like
that don't matter because there's no ads
there's no uh nothing in there at all so
i'm doing my best to
you know to do a service for owners the
owner of this product cared measured
so
you know company needs to pay attention
that you know customers do care it's not
that you know nobody cares and can just
dismiss me out of hand
and i'm hoping other people start
measuring properly too and
you know we get confidence around what
claims there are and what reality is
anyway the device is now packed
and this morning fedex picked it up so i
can't do any more measurements of it if
audi if psrdo comes back with a fifth
answer now on on on all this stuff i
hope they provide measurements and
replicate my results and drive the
conversation that way i don't have one i
do have a
p300 from ps audio about 30 years ago
and i don't ever use it it's sitting in
the back i have my ac generator that's
far cleaner than power plant
i don't use it so it's not like i can't
own these things i own them already if
they did something good i'd use them but
use them in my measurement rig i don't
use them anywhere here because they
don't do anything i use my same dirty
power to measure equipment that produces
state-of-the-art in noise and distortion
so clearly
dirty power is fine so how often do you
hear that
alrighty thanks for watching this long
video and i'm sorry i'm boring you with
you know the video on this topic okay
see you in the future hopefully on a
different topic than this one bye bye